okay today I'm going to talk to you
about density so density is basically a
measure of how compact a substances so
how tightly packed together the
particles are so I'm going to use an
example to illustrate this idea so let's
imagine I have two cubes one of those
cubes is one centimeter cubed in volume
and it's made of iron and let's imagine
the other one is jelly but also has a
volume of one centimeter cubed so what
we can do is what I'm going to do is I'm
going to show if we if we just imagine
I'm looking really really close up at a
particular section of this on an atomic
level I could see what the particles
would look like in the iron now iron has
a high density so you could see all the
particles are really really closely
packed together if I have a look at this
enlarged diagram so again on an atomic
level of the jelly we might see that the
particles are much less tightly packed
together so as we can see the iron has a
higher density than the jelly because we
can fit more particles within the same
volume as a result if I measured the
mass of these two I might find that the
iron has a mass of around eight grams
and the jelly has a mass of around two
grams this is despite having the same
volume and this is just due to the fact
that the iron is has a higher density
the particles are more tightly packed
together so in order to there's an
equation that we need to understand to
get our heads around density and it's a
really nice simple equation density
equals mass divided by volume so what
we're going to do now is we're just
going to quickly have a look at these
two specific examples of iron and jelly
in order to find the density of these
two substances so firstly with iron
the density equals the object's mass and
in this case the mass of the iron is 8
grams divided by its volume and in this
case it's 1 centimeter cubed now in
order to find out the units for density
we do it like this so first of all 8
divided by 1 is 8 to find the units we
need to look at the mass and the volume
so this is grams over centimeters cubed
so the units are grams per centimeters
cubed remember this per means divided by
so it's grams divided by centimeters
cube so it's per grams per centimeter
cubed similarly if we have a look at the
jelly it works in exactly the same way
to find V to find the density so again
we want to do mass divided by volume
this time the mass of the jelly is 2
centimeters cubed or sorry 2 grams even
and the volume is 1 centimeter cubed so
just like before we do mass divided by
volume so 2 divided by 1 is 2 and the
units are going to be grams per
centimeter cubed well I just want to
quickly show you a slightly different
example in case we had a different
object so let's imagine we had an object
that had a mass of 10 kilograms and
let's say it had a volume of 5 meters
cubed now in order to find the units for
density of this one again we do mass
divided by volume so 10 divided over 5
is 2 but to find the units this time
it's kilograms per meter cubed so we're
going to write it like this so to find
the units for density it's always mass
per volume so we need to look carefully
at which units we're dealing with here
the final thing that we
to look at is how we can use information
about density to figure out whether an
object would float or whether it would
sink so the density of water pure water
is one gram per centimeter cubed so
let's imagine this here is some water
now if I got my iron cube as we can see
the iron has a higher density than water
so as a result if I put this iron on the
water it would sink because it's got a
higher density however if I had a
different substance for example type of
wood called pine so here's my pine that
has a density of around 0.5 grams per
centimeter cube as you can see this is a
lower density than water so therefore it
would float rather than sinking so
hopefully now we know what density is
how to use the equation and find the
unit of density and how we can use
information about density to find out
whether objects float or sink thank you